(upbeat music)
- [Narrator] Celebrities
love endorsing presidents,
and presidents love
celebrity endorsements.
And this is the story of the
president that started it all.
(upbeat jazz music)
Warren Harding was the 29th
President of the United States.
Before that, Harding was
a pretty generic Senator.
The New York Times even dubbed
him "Faint and Colorless."
So how the hell did he win the presidency?
Three words, Florence Kling Harding,
his wife and true campaigner.
Florence had her ear to the ground.
Any time a famous or
influential person came to town,
she would have them pose for
a photo on their front porch.
So basically, the first political selfie.
Enter Al Jolson:
at the time deemed the
world's greatest entertainer.
(bell dings)
He sang, he danced,
he even landed the first
talking role in a movie.
Most importantly,
he became the first celebrity
to ever endorse a presidential candidate.
Harding had several other
celebrity endorsements;
most notably, Thomas
Edison and Henry Ford.
And guess what?
It worked.
Warren Harding became our 29th President.
And despite going down
as one of the worst
presidents in U.S. history,
his political selfies changed
the landscape forever.
(U.S. Presidential
Anthem: Hail to the Chief)